President Trump is digging in his heels
over the concept of taking the legal and
bureaucratic process out of immigration
enforcement he wants potential illegal
immigrants turned back at the border
without seeing a judge and he insists
it's up to Congress to act quickly to
fix a broken system chief White House
correspondent John Roberts starts us off
on the North Lawn tonight John Bracken
evening the toxic environment
surrounding this summer is illegal
immigrant crisis on the border continues
to build with Trump administration
officials being thrown out of
restaurants and the president wanting to
throw illegal migrants out of the
country meeting with Jordan's King
Abdullah today President Trump was
focused on the Middle East peace process
but it was again immigration that piqued
his interest in a Q&A with reporters we
want strong borders and we want no crime
strong borders we want no crime the
Democrats want open borders and they
don't care about crime the president
said he has no regrets about signing
last week's executive order to keep
families together
shooting down reports that he didn't
want to sign it but he again insisted
that it is Congress that needs to act to
find a permanent solution
the laws are obsolete the laws are
horrible having to do with the border
both in terms of security and in terms
of taking care of people President Obama
had a big problem in fact a lot of the
pictures used they thought would be I
guess I don't know what you folks did
you use pictures from 2014 they were all
taken during the Obama administration
President Trump said today he is dealing
with the same problems that the Obama
administration faced on his policy of
detaining families ending
catch-and-release the president got some
support from President Obama's Homeland
Security Secretary jeh Johnson we
believed it was necessary at the time I
still believe it is necessary to mane a
certain capability for families we can't
have catch and release and in my three
years we deported or repatriated it
returned over a million people in a
weekend tweet President Trump proposed
to reduce the problem of housing illegal
migrants by eliminating the adjudication
process the president writing when
somebody comes in we must immediately
with no judges or court case
bring them back from where they came
many people saw that as the president
scorching due process that's not what
our country stands for we are people
and we do have the White House says
already thousands of people are deported
every year without seeing a judge under
US law illegal migrants from Mexico and
Canada are subject to expedited removal
taken to a border crossing and released
the president's idea would expand that
to include people from non contiguous
countries but the White House insists
there is an easier way we like to see
more expedited removal but ultimately
the president would like to see our
border secured so that we don't have all
of these problems to begin with the
president wants to fix our immigration
system completely not just tinker with
it
the press secretary today also talked
publicly for the first time about a
weekend incident in which she was asked
to leave the red hand restaurant in
Lexington Virginia I was asked to leave
because I work for president Trump we
are allowed to Grist disagree but we
should be able to do so freely and
without fear of harm and this goes for
all people regardless of politics
healthy debate on ideas and political
philosophy is important but the calls
for harassment and push for any Trump
supporter to avoid the public is
unacceptable after she was asked to
leave the redhead restaurant in
Lexington
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and her husband
retired back to where they were staying
for the evening her family decided to go
out to another restaurant in the area
they were followed to that restaurant by
a number of people including the owner
of the Red Hen who continued to protest
their presence outside that restaurant
even though Sarah Sanders was no longer
with the Bret the rest of the story
there John thank you